women 21 years old is virtually raped
by a stranger
in metaverse app yeah may 26th yesterday
right yeah and you read the story of
what uh uh direction we're going to saw
page three
let me read this full article to you
okay a woman was virtually read by
stranger meta horizon worlds metaverse
app while another user watched and
passed around a bottle of vodka
new reports claims about an hour into
using the platform the avatar was
sexually assaulted during a
disorientating and confusing experience
the researchers said it happened so fast
i kind of was dissoci disassociated one
part of my brain was like what the hell
is going on the other part was is in
this isn't a real body and another part
was like this is important research
horizon worlds was uh released by meta
in december and allows users to gather
with others play games and build their
own virtual worlds you know this sounds
weird to us let's just say right because
i'm 43 and you know okay i'm let i'm
seeing this happening but
this is very real where we're going of
course this is the direction we're going
right so it's gonna be the scariest part
about this
is if this becomes a crime i'll just say
this because if this becomes a crime
yeah then the way to be able to
manipulate crime later on i mean this
just opens it up a little bit too much
yeah is there going to be like a now now
that this has happened
do they go like to court and like does
this matter
i don't think you can do that but what i
think is interesting is that
i had somebody say this this is not my
idea so i don't want to steal it but
they said anybody who's buying property
on the metaverse is kind of a fool
because
you just you can't put a value on an
infinite supply of something
the metaverse you know yeah
there's an infinite supply there's an
influence
all it takes is another algorithm you
know so guys are selling a guy sent me a
message yesterday saying i got a special
land for you for sale if you want i want
i'll make i'll let you uh make the first
offer my number is 2.4 million i said
yeah i'm good bro you know i wish you
all the best he said about the metaverse
yeah he's trying to sell me land for 2.4
million a big nfc guy says i'll sell it
to you for 2.4 million this is going to
be five million dollar property i'm like
i'm good yeah totally fine it's gambling
yeah there might be people i mean
people who have made real money off nfl
and and
that but that's all because
it's just like crypto it's it's that's
all because
even though there isn't much of a like
if you if you have bitcoin if you want
to buy a child or a or a
a lot of drugs or a nuclear weapon i
suppose bitcoin would work but for the
most part there's still not really no uh
there's not a real economy that is
girding this or undergirding whatever
the word is but
i do think that isn't isn't and i'm i
don't know but it isn't
bitcoin and all these cryptocurrencies
they are
valued because a lot of people are
buying them just in case
but by the way what he just said has led
to a
uh research i don't know if you saw the
article on how crypto bitcoin is
matching with what the stock market does
meaning the pattern
is now whatever the market does 79 out
of 93 days if the stock went up
bitcoin went up if the stock market went
down bitcoin went down did you see that
the
that article that was texted to you did
you see that article or no kai send it
to us i don't know if you got it or not
it's a very very i thought bitcoin and
uh crypto was supposed to be an
uncorrelated asset i thought it wasn't
supposed to be tied did you read the
start. no i haven't okay so it shows
uh kai if you're listening i don't know
if he's listening or not if he can text
it to us but it matches exactly with
what the stock market did
uh uh that article right there bitcoin
is acting like the stock market and
that's not that's not that that's 2018.
hey kai do you know the article you send
me about how
bitcoin and stock market are correlating
can you text it to me uh i just send
them a text right now through audio but
it shows so that right there is not a
good sign by the way that's not good
because if it's mainstream yeah then
then it's not good so then
but the part of it that the bitcoin
community can say it's good is what well
guess what legitimate no no no yeah
we're not only legitimate bring some of
the bigger money because it's like it's
the same thing as stock market bring
that in but then you lose your identity
of being you know we're we're owned you
know we're we're own libertarian we've
got our own goes back to what you were
saying though it goes back to
the fact that okay you're saying this is
valued at x okay
but
where is the exchange of goods and
services
you know the dollar i can understand
even though we have quantitative easing
and stuff but for the most part you and
i decide that though the market decides
the value yes and by the way i'm not a
i'm not a big i have bitcoin and have
ethereum but i'm not a guy that's going
around telling everybody go buy bitcoin
but all i'm saying is the market will
determine what's what's what's crazy the
last couple years is that gold is
gold is no longer what it was because
like right now what is the price of gold
a kilo of gold right now tyler if you
type in a price of of gold kilo what is
it right now 57 000 it's a gas 59 000
500 okay
my price is 61 000 okay
so
if it if it went based on what the
market was doing yeah
it should be a hundred thousand dollars
it should be eighty thousand dollars
right but the patterns of how gold
reacts to what happens to the market is
not happening that 1554
peter schiff has been saying that's
going to be 5 000 for 20 years
it's eventually going to get to 5
thousand so he's eventually gonna say i
told you i was right but 20 years too
late of saying i was right right
so there's certain things that's
confusing i think the next two years you
you almost need the next two years to
see what moves what doesn't
so everyone's gonna know if bitcoin goes
one direction
and then you know interest rates go up
bitcoin goes up but stock market goes
down that's when the bitcoin community
right there look at that
bitcoin has been trading with the stock
market this year okay
uh uh what's the day that he has that he
just texted you
what's the number of days look at u.s
dollars he dude look at that look how
close it is wow look how close that that
means people are being careful isn't it
isn't that because people don't have as
much confidence and they want they want
to link it to something that's been
proven to be real for a long time you
mean with bitcoin or the stock market
bitcoin they're calling it digital gold
right now okay go go to that article
that's one i want to read okay can you
make a little bigger bitcoin has often
been linked to a digital version of gold
which for years has been safe haven
asset known as a
tr uh thrusty structure
trusty store value when times have been
more uncertain but evidence for bitcoin
fulfilling a similar role is hard to
find in this year at least indeed the
data of 2022 suggests the price of
bitcoin often moves in the same
direction as stocks rather than the
opposite of the 98 trading days we've
had so far
bitcoin and s p 500 index have moved in
the same direction 73 of them wow that
that wow so i want to know what the
bitcoin community says to that while
moving in the opposite direction only 25
times the biggest moves in the stocks
like the u.s stocks fell 3.2 percent of
my ninth also came the largest moves of
bitcoin for the stats nerds the
correlation between the two has been
plus 0.53 interesting so how are you
processing that how should it be moving
differently it's so you're not unique
you are the stock market you're not
unique you don't so versus what i would
have wanted to see is
if the market goes down the next six to
12 months and they raise interest rates
i'd like to see
if i'm if i'm a pro bitcoin guy i would
want to see bitcoin go up
i'd want it to go up to sixty thousand
seventy thousand eighty thousand ninety
000 if it does they have the argument
the same way as if gold goes up the next
12 to 18 months because gold is the
armageddon sale right the world's coming
to an end you better own some gold you
know
brian you gotta put them put aside five
percent of portfolio go buy some gold
and set aside but if it doesn't go that
way then the gold audience that's
selling gold their argument is kind of
their own investors are going to be like
hey john you told me the last eight
years if the interest rates go up gold's
gonna go to five thousand it's still at
fifteen fifty what the hell is going on
well you know what's different about
this time they lose the argument so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]